data studio is Google's next generation
business intelligence and data
visualization platform that lets you
build scalable serverless
interactive dashboards on the cloud free
of charge
hi I'm in-house Kazi developer advocate
for data studio in this video we will
take a look at two new exciting features
in data studio Explorer and data
blending I'll also show you how you can
take advantage of these features in data
studio when you're working with the data
set you want to first explore the data
you want to start with an overview of
the data explore it and look for
insights to code been Schneiderman's
visualization mantra overview first zoom
and filter and details-on-demand so when
you're doing more of an exploratory
visualization you need the capability to
select exactly the data you need filter
it based on different criteria and try
different visualizations to see what
makes more sense data studio Explorer is
a dedicated space for you to quickly
derive insights from your data through
fast ad-hoc query it is built on top of
the same stack as data studio so
everything created in Explorer can be
exported into Data store reporting and
everything visualized in data studio
reporting can be exported into the
Explorer for quick analyzes this
Explorer feature becomes more important
when you're working with big data for
example in bigquery bit query is
Google's petabyte scale data warehouse
solution in bigquery you can use sequel
to query terabytes in seconds let's see
how you can use data studio Explorer
feature with the bigquery data set
you're going to love this once you have
your data in bigquery what can you do
what if you want to quickly visualize
the results of your data or what if you
have users who don't know how to write
sequel but still need to work with the
data so here's my query and we'll pick a
public data set from here this is the
public data set for Major League
Baseball and we'll pick this table and
we will run a sample query we'll pick
all the fields and we'll remove the
limit and then we'll run the query so
what's the query is run then you can see
that we can see the
results of the query we also had this
button called exploring data studio if
we click this button what will happen is
that data studio will create a direct
connection to the bigquery table and
we'll set up the ad-hoc visual querying
interface where I can drag and drop
chips that generate the sequel queries
in bigquery so this table contains every
major league baseball event at bat from
2016
so first let's say we want to answer the
question what is the venue capacity of
each venue for that first we'll look for
the venue cities will add the city to
dimension and will add the capacity to
the metric and we can see that these
capacities are very large numbers
because it's summing up all the results
so instead of the sum will pick average
and now we can see the venue capacity of
these venues so let's say we want to
also filter this by state so we'll pick
the states and we will add the venue
state measure as a filter and select
California as the filtering state and
we'll apply and now you can see all the
venues in California and the relevant
capacities this is how easy it is to use
this Explorer interface now I can also
switch this table to a bar chart or I
can even switch this to a geo map I can
also remove this filter and then not say
whatever results I have I want to put
this new report and share that with my
stakeholders that is also possible to do
I will save this Explorer option and
then I will take this and put it into a
new data studio report
data's Explorer is 100% interpretable
with data story reporting so I can move
visualizations created here to data
studio reporting with one-click and now
data studio is exporting my
visualizations to this report and here
you can see the report I can now add a
filter for the state and then I can
share this report with my other
stakeholders where they can easily
filter and see the results if you want
to get valuable insights from your data
you might bring in data from different
sources then you want to combine analyze
and visualize your combine data as a
whole when you combine multiple datasets
based on common parameters the
visualization give you better context to
the data for example you might want to
join your daily cells data by geographic
region with that region's daily average
temperature to see how the temperature
affected sales this can be useful if you
are let's say an ice cream manufacturer
data studio lets you bring in data from
different sources and visualize them
side by side on the same dashboard page
however the data blending feature will
let you join those datasets and analyze
filter and visualize them in the same
visual component let's see how easily
data blending works in data studio in
this example we'll walk through how easy
it is to blend your data in data studio
will blend your Google Analytics data
with some public data if you want to do
this without blending it will require
exporting data from the original system
like analytics using an API or manual
exports and then joining the data in a
tool like Google sheets or be query
using blending you can combine the data
in DDS to do and continue to take
advantage of the direct connection to
your data to get started let's assume
you have two data sources the first one
is the Google Analytics data and a set
of public data set that shows the US
population on a state basis so this is
let's say we will add the public
information first we will add the
population public data source for
dimensional ad region and for metric
will add the population
so you can see each region and their
population so we add a second table
where we'll bring in the Google
Analytics data and similarly over here
we'll bring in region and also user
count
so what we want to do is we want to
blend these two data sources and have
one table where we'll have the region
the population and the users and it is
very easy to do that in data studio what
we will do is we'll select both of the
tables right click select blend data and
then ds3 will give us a new table that
will have a new blended data source with
both of these fields present so as you
can see over here in this table that is
blended we have the region the
population and the users and that is how
easy it is to blend data in data studio
so data Explorer lets you quickly
generate insights from your data in
addition to leveraging powerful
visualizations in reports and data
blending lets you join your data from
multiple sources and visualize them in
the same component to provide additional
context these new features will help you
to get a better understanding of your
data and get actionable insights in a
shorter time in data studio go to data
studio Google calm and try out these new
features today
[Music]